nothing can stop us says presidential
hopeful anome we're exercising our basic
right she adds we have an appointment
with the sagales people Security Forces
prevent her from meeting party
supporters then she's arrested accused
of taking part in an illegal Gathering a
masked officer is seen forcing her into
a police van hours before the start of
campaigning on Saturday president makis
cancelled this month's presidential
election he says he's protecting
democracy and isn't trying to extend his
own
term but his decision is fueling
widespread anger in a district of Dar
named Liberty protesters showing their
Defiance the cancellation of the vote is
seen as an injustice protesters say once
again the powerful are robbing them of
the chance to make their own
future we are in a country where people
are mistreated it's really tough for us
the world needs to understand this this
is a cry from the heart I'm a struggling
entrepreneur I have a master's degree
I'm left selling coffee on the streets
there's no work jobs are given to those
with political
connections we want work we want to work
for our country our time has come now
they're protesting where the opposition
is calling a constitutional coup and
block an Avenue leading to the
presidential Palace they're urging
others to join their
Revolt there's been running battles
between protest ERS that have been
throwing rocks and the police that have
been responding by firing tear gas they
want to prevent this Gathering to take
place but supporters of the opposition
are determined to gather and to get
their voices heard the West African
Regional organization echos the US and
France have all expressed concern and
urged the announcement of an election
date you feel that it could burn at any
point and this is not what we deserve
because the people themselves no
religious conflict no ethnic conflict
but you have localized politician
partisan conflicts and they threaten to
destroy s social fabric what been
regarded as the most stable democracy in
West Africa no longer seems so stable
Nicholas Hawk Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
is
zero